uh my name's Trevor uh and uh I'm going
to be talking a little bit about uh a
Climate Services tool that we've been
working on for about five years
now so I'll be Begin by talking about
why we built the library uh how we built
it to be useful for multiple types of
activities uh go over a bit of the
eternals uh as well as uh a live
demonstration uh and I'll end with the
credits so before anything uh what is
Orono so uh oros is a Consortium of
around 60 uh researchers Educators and
project managers uh based out of uh
Montreal Quebec Canada uh and our goal
is to provide approachable uh and
specific climate information for various
stakeholders uh in the province of
Quebec and internationally uh we're a
climate service provider so we concern
ourselves with transforming research and
simulation data into simple and useful
plots uh or tables uh things that are e
easy for people to uh digest uh we also
run our own Regional climate model
experiments uh and so we're very
familiar with working with uh very large
data um yeah so myself uh Trevor James
Smith I'm uh a uh I I'm in the pl
climate platforms data and operations
team alongside my um uh my partner for
this uh presentation unfortunately it
couldn't be here Pascal
boo so before anything uh it's always
good to know why we're doing the things
that we are doing and uh yeah climate
change is occurring on Earth life is on
Earth and it's going to affect life so a
lot of people are concerned um the
United Nations has the uh sustainable
sustainable development goals so number
13 is uh taking climate action uh I put
the climate clock in New York as well uh
so what can we do about it well we have
physics we have programming we can
generate climate models
which leads to making experiments uh and
hopefully from these experiments we can
get actionable
information but there's a bit of a
problem because everybody's making
climate models everybody's running
experiments uh there's more and more
data uh more and more problems that we
have to deal with uh in the bottom here
this is just kind of an example of all
these different model simulations of
Earth's climate and well none of them
are correct uh there's lots of uh VAR
ability there's lots of uh internal
changes uh internal differences between
all the different models and so we have
to figure out how to make the extract
the useful information out of all this
uh at the same time we are also having
to deal with uh model data which uh is
growing and growing in size uh with uh
every year so this is just um a graph uh
projecting change from 2010 uh into 2030
uh and the volume of data is just
constantly growing as uh as models
become more numerous in their number uh
experiments are more numerous uh and
stimulations are run for uh many
different
reasons so what are we doing about it
well one way that we can do one the way
that we can tackle this is by creating
climate data platforms so one thing is
we can do is uh generating uh these kind
of like portraits or platforms that give
us uh a way of searching through the
data and getting uh useful things out of
it so uh Canada has a has climate datca
Quebec uh we offer one called uh whoops
I pressed the wrong thing yeah so we
have one that's called pavic uh and uh
in Europe we have cernus uh and there's
plenty others like the Microsoft
planetary computer uh but is that
helping well it does because we have
more relevant customize specific
information we are using less bandwidth
uh we're not having to download a norm
uh enormous chunks of data in order to
get the things that we need makes it a
lot more available uh and then there's
ultimately we're spending more time
doing research and less time managing
data so this is one example here of uh
climate
dat.com groups of models maybe we want
to have uh Ensemble statistics like the
10th the 90th the 50th percentile
according to uh some emission scenario
so here we have this is degree days
below a threshold maybe I'm curious
about that because I'm concerned about
hockey rinks being available uh in the
future maybe it's going to be too warm
for us to have outdoor hockey ranks I I
hope
not um behind all that uh is uh xlim so
exim is uh an operational library that
we've been uh building for a long time
uh and we uh ideally want to uh well the
reason why we did it was to have control
over our algorithms our uh and ensure
that standards are good uh and have
transparency of the code so developing
software to Ser better serve our needs
the idea behind that was at the time we
were a bunch of researchers we had our
own ways of doing our of doing things
and ensuring that uh results are
replicable even within our team was very
challenging so we wanted to build a tool
that we could all use internally uh and
then additionally we wanted to have this
tool be able to be an Engine That Could
power things such as uh climate
data.csv aderes to the standards that
you expect of climate and forecasting uh
and then also we wanted to have it open
source we wanted to be able to uh you
know show our work and be able to
benefit from
contributions so uh yeah in many cases
so uh climate indexes uh are uh they
could be calculated almost as on liners
it might be like a a mean over time uh
based on temperature that would give you
your mean temperature but we wanted to
do a little bit more than that because
there's a lot of kind of intricacies to
working with climate data um there's uh
the concerns about uh units management
so if we're working with temperature
data that's in kelvin versus uh
Fahrenheit uh that's something that we
need to think about uh ensuring that the
metadata is correct uh is really
important uh for us and then dealing
with things like Ensemble statistics for
large uh ensembles of models uh every
model has uh has bias so we need to
figure out how to deal with that and
then uh we wanted to make sure that
there was Data quality assurance checks
in addition to that so in our
implementation we were aiming for
something that was operational uh
foolproof uh and able to be uh built
upon uh and yeah just to mention a
climate indicator is any function that
summarize weather information Into
Climate scale information so this could
be simple to Statistics over a certain
time frame so mean temperature number of
days or precipitation
Etc uh yeah so for the average user um
maybe they they might just be concerned
with with indicators but we've actually
built this tool into being something
that is uh much larger than that so we
have our our Ensemble module we have a
statistical uh and bias adjustment
statistical downscaling and bias
adjustment module uh we have utilities
for dealing with different calendars
missing units things like that um as of
December uh we're at version 0.47 so
that give us around 187 official climate
indicators uh and around 90 of these uh
deal with precipitation in temperature
alone uh so as I mentioned uh yeah we we
we were building this with dask uh and
numpy and uh Numba uh or and xarray and
so one thing that we were able to do
because we're sticking so close to that
stack is our data structure is very easy
uh to be used with uh the Pango uh data
structure as well so we can do things
like uh we can pass uh our data objects
to pretty much anything that's built on
uh pandis or uh xarray uh and vice versa
um and then for our statistical
algorithms uh we're sticking very like
everything is in in the open source
realm so we're still using dask we're
still using pandas numpy but we're also
uh We've also built a few things of our
own um and uh We've sped that all up
using uh things like Numba uh in order
to ensure that our metadata and uh all
the units and conventions are good uh
we're basing ourselves on cfx array
which is an imple it's an xarray based
uh CF uh or climate and forecasting
conventions Tool uh and so that ensures
that we're we're able to have uh the
proper Dimensions that you would expect
from climate and forecasting data uh
with pint uh using for used for for uh
unit
conversion um yeah and we're we're we're
planning on moving this to Pint x-ray
very soon uh we have our own our our
whole we have a whole module for pint uh
that we're trying to move that up um and
we're moving we've already in the past
we've moved quite a lot of things
Upstream as well so we've made
contributions uh to CF time we've made
contributions for calendar conversion
and xray uh pint uh as well uh We've
even moved a few things into numpy and
we also uh maintain and regularly do
pushes to uh things like xmf intake ESF
cfx array uh things like
that so internally we uh we divide so
the the indicator module is probably the
largest module and this what most people
will use uh and we've divided this into
uh two kind of synonymous uh API so one
API is for we call it the the indicator
API and then the other one is called the
indices uh API so if you want to if if
you don't care about all the metadata
checks and all that what you can do is
you can say I just want to run I run one
of the I want to run a computation uh
it'll do maybe an input unit check to
make sure well if you're passing
temperature data to uh something that
works only on precipitation it's going
to say you can't do that uh and then it
will do the computation and it'll give
you something exactly back which will be
an X-Ray object with a numpy or dat
array um or if you want kind of like
everything else so this would include
checks to make sure that the metadata is
good that your cell methods are good uh
your frequency checks so making sure
that the data is in the proper time
frequency um that's all performed before
you even hit computation and then after
that uh we'll do things like ensuring
that the units are good uh and we can do
things uh additional things like
ensuring that if there's any uh if
there's any slices that have too much
missing data then we're going to drop
them because we don't want to we don't
consider them valid uh and finally we
can do things like adding very specific
metadata so that kind of that kind of
makes it fullprof uh and uh more of an
operational uh tool than anything else
uh and so what we want to do on top of
this so I mean if we're if we can ensure
that we're always getting the same
things out uh we can also extend upon
this so the uh there's two ways that we
can extend xlim so one way is to
literally just add add new uh indicators
uh directly into xlim and you can add a
pull request if you want but we also
built a way of making we call them
virtual subm modules so this would be if
we wanted to create a library like an
extra Library based on the uh the like a
generic set of uh climate indices or
indexes we could write this all out
using this kind of like yaml
configuration and say we want to use the
count occurrences Indy using U minimum
temperature data we're like doing a some
we want to make sure that our our
metadata uh looks good at the end and
these are the parameters that we're
passing through it uh and so you can
essentially build your own module uh if
you if you so desire and that will give
you the data you
expect uh yeah so the the last segment
here is the bias adjustment module so uh
for those who are unfamiliar with
climate model outputs they're very
similar to any other model output where
you need to correct what's coming out
what we have uh coming from a model data
it's often too hot or too cold uh and
you need to ensure that the uh
distribution of uh of values is uh
Compares well with today uh I'm not the
statistician on the team but if ever you
have a question feel free to ask it in
our
GitHub so I wanted to make sure that
there's enough time for the live
demonstration so I'll see if this
works uh
okay here we go uh are you able to see
it uh okay I'll assume that you do
um all right
so uh hello hello oh my
God all right I'm going to assume that
this is good uh yeah so for for this I'm
going to give a uh a really small
analysis or a really small kind of uh
playthrough of this so this is just
showing uh what we can do with xlim
right off the bat so we uh I'm going to
start with the first demo which is the
climate indicator calculation so uh this
is going to just show that calculations
are are you know that that we can kind
of like uh work with um unit management
and things like that and uh Missing data
I'll just start here so we uh this first
demo is on uh the indicator calculation
and unit management so we want to
calculate monthly growing days above
five degrees Celsius uh we want to
ensure that there's identical results
regardless of our input so if we're
playing with Kelvin or Fahrenheit or
Celsius and we want to ensure that um
yeah we want to ensure that we're that
everything is is entirely consistent so
in this example here we're importing
xlim we're using uh The Growing Degree
Days indicator so we have our
temperature in celsius with a threshold
in Celsius we have a temperature in
fahrenheit with a threshold in Celsius
and then our Fahrenheit temperature and
a Kelvin um uh example
here so if we run this you can see right
off the bat that uh no matter what you
give it it's always going to be
consistent so this is very important
when we're working with uh data that's
coming in different uh in different uh
units or maybe if we want to ensure that
we're getting a specific unit out uh
this is this is very uh useful that we
don't have to in that we don't have to
deal with this
ourselves uh for missing data there's a
whole bunch of ways that we can kind of
handle the uh the missing data problem
so uh Missing data can happen very often
with in uh with observed data sets so
things coming from stations uh it's a
it's a major concern uh and if we want
to be able to be using it properly for
uh for some statistical reason then we
need to ensure that we're dropping the
slices that are no good so a couple ways
that we can do that is by using the uh
World Meteorological organization
standards uh we can have a uh a
percentage of missing data that's
allowed per uh per slice uh we can also
just have an arbitrary count of missing
uh of missing values that's allowed or
um yeah and there there's a few other
ways that we can do it so here we're uh
we're setting tolerances here for uh 25%
and 5% uh and we're concerned about uh
we're using temperature or Min Min
temperature in order to calculate our
ice days so ice days are are being um
temperatures where or days where the
maximum temperature is below uh 0
degrees C so if we run this and it's
quite fast we can see here that uh when
we have a threshold of 25% missing data
we have 101 valid years for uh the
station that we're looking at here and
then if we're a little bit more
stringent then it's going to start
removing uh our valid the uh it's going
to start removing years where there's
more missing data so this is very useful
for
uh you know if you want to do an
analysis in an area that has uh very has
very sparse readings uh we kind of leave
it up to you to to be able to play
around with that um given that we're
working we're operating in in Quebec one
thing that we want to do is we want to
uh ensure that our metadata is is INF
frenched so we built our own uh
internationalization uh like metadata
standard so with this we can set our
metadata local to for French and and we
can see that in our attributes here we
have our our standard name so this is a
this is a controlled vocabulary coming
from the climate and forecasting
conventions uh our long name which is
kind of like an explanation uh and
you'll notice that the long name will
have uh the thresholds and uh relevant
information uh directly put into there
so we passed uh for this this was a this
is um mean day mean temperature with uh
days with mean temperature above 5
degrees cus and so here we go and then
uh yeah we have the we have it in French
as well and it's syntactically correct
so that's
fantastic um so our we we then have our
ensembles of uh of climate simulation so
this is very important when we're doing
analyses based on uh multiple uh models
and so if we want to be able to kind of
get our some Ensemble statistics what we
can do is we can start by well loading
our data so this is a data set that we
have available on our pavic platform uh
and then we're going to kind of like
compare and see what we can how we can
put that together so we start by
creating an ensemble well actually sorry
uh I'll just say really quickly here
that um one thing that we need to manage
here is that there are multiple
calendars for for these data so some
some models use a 360-day year some of
them use a no leap year and some use uh
the the standard calendar uh and that's
something that uh is is a challenge to
deal with and we've actually with our
Ensemble uh with our Ensemble module we
actually are able to uh put this all
together and ensure that uh any data
like any like days we we can synchronize
the days properly uh using a variety of
different options so uh that's all done
under the hood if you don't want to go
into it you don't have to so that's a
one of the beauties of this so running
this we're able to see okay well we have
all of this all of this climate all this
climate model data and this this
beautiful uh rainbow spaghetti which
doesn't really tell us much but if we
want what we can do is we can take the
uh we can start running uh percentiles
uh we can do it a percentile uh analysis
to do the 10th the 50th the 90th and
then running this we get uh we get uh
the yeah the spread of uh possible
values so this is done and I mean this
is being done on a very large data set
very quickly uh and it's all with the
help of dask so I'll just show really
quickly here that um our our entire our
our module or our um our library is is
fully consistent with dask so if you
load things with uh X array using chunks
you're going to get uh you're going to
get dask arrays uh which are uh only
calculated when they when you ask for it
so that's uh that's kind of cool so yeah
so I mean even if you you say you want
to do a particular analysis it can be uh
it'll it's not going to give you any
value until you ask for one so I'm not
going to run this because it takes a
little bit of time but uh essentially
you'll you'll only uh run the analysis
when you need it um yeah I see that I'm
running a bit uh low on time so I think
I'm GNA go I'm GNA switch
back here we go uh yeah and I'll just
say that here that um so who's using
exim um lots of people there's um uh IIM
there's a climate datca there's a whole
B we've even have a few examples of xlim
being used in the Microsoft planetary
computer uh we use it all as well
internally uh in our pavic platform as
you just saw uh and we're also uh
building we're producing our own data
sets using this uh this data or or this
uh Library as well um we also use it in
xn which is a another offering from oros
that does uh
workflows uh and we're at 270 stars on
GitHub so what's next uh the last thing
that we were working on well the things
that we want work on next is that we
want to have um algorithms algorithm
improvements to make them a little bit
more zippier uh we want uh our
documentation to be a little bit more
clean uh and then more of just building
out uh more things maybe more Realms
more indicators things like that uh
we're going to be migrating some
functions upstream and then uh we've
been in version zero for a very long
time so we're thinking of maybe it going
to version
one uh I asked the same thing to chat
GPT and uh it gave me uh pretty much
exactly what I expected and it's exactly
what we were planning and that was a
little bit terrifying but it's good to
know that we're on the right track
so who's behind it I just want to thank
uh uh my the core development team so
Pascal uh who couldn't be here um like
all of these people uh are contributors
uh and if you ever feel uh the need to
look at what we have uh please uh feel
free to read our paper with which
published in JS recently um or check out
our GitHub thank you very
much
fantastic thank you for the talk yeah
it's time we've got five minutes left if
there are any questions anyone might
have feel free to put them in the
chat yeah I see here uh so uh yeah so
from Aid uh TR very interest talk sorry
I missed this during the presentation in
what context are you using x-ray data
structure uh librarian xlim um in what
context are you using xray data well I
think well so exim is entirely based on
xray so uh so long as you pass any type
of xray uh object so we mostly work on
data arrays uh you it will it will
understand and it will give you exactly
what you expect uh we're working on some
new features to kind of uh start passing
directly data sets so that we can do
things like managing uh the global
attributes but uh but right now we have
a very very strong uh data array
management
uh like the entire the entire library is
built around that so yeah F funny enough
one thing that chat GPT mentioned was uh
that we should try operating uh on Pi on
on pandas arrays and that actually had
got us thinking that maybe that's not a
terrible idea so we might be doing that
uh in the future anyway um so yeah how
large of Ensemble data sets have you
been able to generate grass for what
were the run times uh so we um well
right now uh we're developing um a set
or two I guess yeah two sets of uh
climate data that are available well
they will be available uh soon publicly
but uh right now they're they're
currently under review uh and they are
10 kilometer they're 10 kilometer
Regional data sets uh for I think at
least eight or nine climate variables uh
covering the entirety of North America
so crunching that
you do need some you do need some power
behind that but uh the fact that we can
that we can start that we can crunch
that on um on like our
workstations uh is is really cool like
dask is is super powerful for being able
to do that uh in the previously we we
put out similar products in the past
using uh the the the net cdf4 library
and lots of kind of like ways to treat
the fact that like we couldn't hold the
data in memory uh and that would running
that would take months um and now we're
creating uh much higher resolution data
uh and it's taking maybe I don't know a
week to to to Really put some to put
something out so it's uh it's like night
and day uh it's quite it's quite
impressive and I mean uh just that that
example before where I was looking at
the uh like the uh The Ensemble The
Ensemble analysis like running that uh
took took about I don't know maybe uh
takes about a minute or so using four
CPUs uh and it's a very large data set
we're talking in the uh in like the the
ter like hundreds of terabyte scale or
no uh yeah no hundreds of hundreds of uh
I think it's hundreds of gigabytes that
sale anyway but uh it's quite it's quite
performant we've we've benchmarked it a
little
bit Yeah so uh yeah feel free please
feel free to check out uh our uh our
website uh check out uh oros sn/ exim uh
we generally get back to people uh
within 24 hours and uh if ever you have
uh a question or you want to uh add
something we we we love it it's
fantastic uh yeah so thank you so much
for for having me and I hope everyone
has a good rest of your conference